okay let's let's go to our next caller
why don't we try the 845 area code
caller from 845 who's this go ahead
hey I'm mark Benjamin I want to run
something by you real quick all right go
ahead
you know you know how conspiracy
theories or just looking for different
channels between the left and the right
some are more crazy some are more like
moderate yeah what's a good way to shop
you know you know shop for information
so that you could just kind of make your
own minds I personally just try to find
either the moderates or if it's someone
on the right someone that would hoard
libertarian I look for someone that
would definitely criticize Trump on
something and on the liberal end I'll
look for somebody that goes like she's
not Satan right there's no set I mean
listen you're doing the right thing mark
in that you're recognizing that you're
likely getting an incomplete story no
matter where you go you're recognizing
that on a lot of issues the truth is
somewhere in the middle although I think
it's fallacious to say that it's always
right in the middle I think that that
that's a wrong starting point so you're
already asking a lot of the right
questions that probably means you're
probably generally like a somewhat
skeptical guy about what you hear in the
news right pretty much yeah so you're
that's half the battle or even more
that's probably 80 percent of the battle
beyond that try to first identify what
are the facts and what are the opinions
about a certain issue because you can
also even if you just were to look at
left-wing and right-wing opinion you
could still develop a sense of what the
facts are by seeing what the non
editorialized components of both left
and right wing reporting are now there's
also lots of facts that often will not
appear on one side or the other but do
that as a starting point and then try to
get reports from like Reuters or The
Associated Press that ideally and of
course there's always some bias and
excuse me inherent in any report but
would at least try to stick to the facts
and then try to also develop an
understanding of the subject from
outside the political reporting like for
example if we're talking about the
government shutdown right and you're
gonna see left-wing here this is about
the shutdown right-wing pieces about the
shutdown pieces purporting to just be
news about the shutdown it's good to
take a step back from the stuff being
reported now and do a little bit of
research about the history of government
shutdowns more generally that's not tied
to the news story now and I think with
that you're going to be ahead of 99% of
news consumers all right and for the guy
that called last time the one before the
one that was a little bit off yeah
the best places to look for information
about the job he caught economy is like
people that are funny enough more
libertarian leaning because they tend to
be us there's they tend to be the type
that would look up as much information
as they can I totally disagree what so
you're making an assertion there on that
gang libertarian oh no no what I learn
information
no no no not those live returns I'm not
I'm not talking about the ones that says
I'm talking about they're leaning as in
that 10 like wealth research group or
rogue money they tend to be in like of
course there's some some left there's
some left sites that I know of I forgot
his name but the ones that I got like
the the the best map out of what's
happening or at least what they theorize
what's happening and they tend to be
right more consistently but I also try
to dabble around everything like I said
before and since I'm not quite um well
learned on every single aspect of it
yeah I have to rely on those sources ok
I would question those sources I've not
heard of those but I would question I I
wouldn't just say that those are the
sources listen but let's leave it there
I think we've said a lot here mark and
maybe we'll pick up on that second issue
at another point because we're going off
off a little bit there